Here in the U.S, The Food and Drug Administration or FDA,
is responsible for regulating medical devices.
The details are complex,
but the level of FDA oversight generally increases with
the perceived patient risk presented by the device.
Devices that perform the same function ha already approved predicate devices,
and do not introduce new risks or generally subject to minimal regulations.
Novel devices must go through a far more complex,
expensive, and time consuming process.
What about medical apps?
Given finite resources and the scale of app development,
it was clear that the FDA had to draw a line
to determine which apps it would even consider.
In February 2015, the agency announced plans
to only review mobile medical apps that interpret data,
and act like medical devices.
The agency says it will only regulate apps that present
a greater risk to patients if they do not work as intended,
or that cause smartphones or other mobile platforms to have
impact on the functionality or performance of traditional medical devices.
More specifically, the agency does not intend to regulate apps that help patients
self-manage their disease or condition without providing specific treatment suggestions.
Provide patients with simple tools to organize and track their health information.
Provide easy access and information related to health conditions or treatments.
Help patients document, show or
communicate potential medical conditions to health care providers.
Automate simple tasks for health care providers,
or enable patients or providers interact with
personal health records or electronic health record systems.
The FDA will also not oversee
the mobile devices such as smartphones and tablets which can run medical apps.
To a large degree,
this decision leaves quality control in the hands of app developers,
providers, and their patients.